The ethnographic museum is a traditional building constructed in the middle of the 18th century, 1764, by Kaplan Pasha Toptani.
Its architecture is oriental with a closed corridor, a type of two-story tower with stone walls 60 to 80 cm wide.
Baroque and Islamic paintings adorn its main rooms.
From the entrance, the arches of the gates with carved stones and the cobbled streets stand out.
Inside, many elements of the area's tradition, from lifestyle to dresses and customs, are found.
At the entrance, there are models of natural water sources, proving that Kruya had some of them.
It is even thought that the origin of the city's name comes from the word Kroi, which means Kruya in Albanian.
From the first floor lobby, visitors acquaint themselves with traditional farming tools,
mechanisms for grinding grain by hand and with water, and the process of cleaning grain for hasher, a traditional dessert.
One exhibit showcases the tanning or processing of leather and the subsequent production of shoes.
Visitors also learn about the processing of swamp straw and the production of hastras for sitting or sleeping within the premises of the house.
In the workshops on the first floor, visitors can observe ironworking for the family's needs and the market of Kruya,
as well as ceramics production, including tiles, bricks and household objects.
In another workshop, there is a distillery where brandy, raki and wine were produced.
Additionally, visitors can observe a water mill used for grinding grain, a valence used to make felt or wool, and the processing of sheep wool used to make fez.
The last workshop houses the olive oil mill, with many amphorae used to store olive oil for an extended period.
The second floor of the apartment begins with the ladies' room or the bride's rooms, where distinguishable boxes held the bride's dowry, all original to the 18th century.
The mural paintings from the same era adorn the walls alongside two distinct types of windows,
above adorned with gypsum works for light and below for ventilation, with wooden frames.
Next, the corridor serves as a link between the rooms, showcasing wedding dresses for both the groom and the bride, embroidered with silk, gold, silver and river pearls, inksy.
A notable feature is the low doors in every room, prompting a respectful gesture of lowering one's head upon entering or leaving.
Moving on to the men's room, the most captivating and original part of the 18th century apartment.
Inside, you'll find a ceiling adorned with weaponry, along with a chimney opposite to the family room wall.
The dome-shaped ceiling, covered with glass and holes in the walls for steam ventilation, are distinctive features.
Adjacent is a section on the balcony of the upstairs living room where children were seated separately to eat.
Additionally, you'll find the chimney that heats the room and the water for the hammam, bath, as well as the utensils or loom used for carpet weaving.
The kitchen boasts an original aspirator-type chimney and various ceramic, copper and wooden dishes.
Interestingly, the kitchen also serves as a bedroom for the elders of the family.
Exiting, you'll encounter carnation tools and ceiling rosettes over 300 years old, alongside the pantry and a canning room for winter fruits and vegetables.
In the spacious bedroom, clothes of both Catholic and Muslim traditions, originating from Kruja or other regions, are displayed.